bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors la situation
d'abord humanitaire qui préoccupe
évidemment la communauté internationale
et ses conséquences
également vous pouvez vous me dire
disons que la situation est dramatique
si l'on peut dire puisque vous avez plus
de 45000 personnes qui ont qui sont au
soudan aujourd'hui qui sont la région du
tigre et en même temps il faut pas
oublier qu'il y avait déjà cent mille
érythréens qui était dans les temps au
niveau du tigre est donc la situation à
venir elle est très alarmante puisque
même si aujourd'hui les couloirs
humanitaires vont peut-être commence à
s'ouvrir il faudra un peu de temps pour
toute cette population et je vous parle
pas des déplacés tigréens qui ont
augmenté notre intelligence suite au
combat
donc la situation est assez dramatique
survint alors sur le front des combats
justement le gouvernement éthiopien
affirme avoir pris repris en tout cas la
capitale à du tigre est donc cette
région dissidente ce que réfute
justement le front de libération du
peuple du tigré
que faut-il en penser parce qu'on a très
peu finalement d'information si c'est
difficile pour les journalistes de se
rendre compte de la situation sur place
alors vous avez raison il n'y a aucune
communication pratiquement 2 du type
élèves donc le front de libération du
papier tigre est la seule communication
colonna c'est celle du gouvernement si
l'on peut dire et tout ce qu'on peut
voir aujourd'hui c'est oui mais qu'elle
ait été repris mais je dirais qu elle
mais qu'elle était repris sans combats a
priori vous le verrez aucune image de
combat de toutes les villes potiers
repris scheer est absolument ravie
gratte même mais quel est donc ça vient
faire priori le tipi l'efs a déserté les
villes à freiner ou résiste un tout
petit peu à la rvm et a préféré prendre
la poudre d'escampette et rester dans
cette position de résistance à
l'extérieur des 1000 pour ne pas
soumettre mais qu'elle est un peu aérée
à si l'on peut lire ou feu d'artillerie
doivent donc pour l'instant le
gouvernement éthiopien a plus ou moins
gagné son premier objectif c'est à dire
de l'invs estime intérêts de mettre en
place un gouvernement de transition ce
parce que les google et les élections
aient lieu date à laquelle on ne sait
pas à qui aura quelques uns des lieux
voilà maintenant la deuxième partie des
objectifs de la gamme end le premier
ministre éthiopien c'est de récupérer ce
qu'il appelle la clique ses dirigeants
du tplf
et les mettre en prison non alors alors
justement sur les forces en présence ce
que c'est on du tplf au niveau des
forces armées du rapport de forces aussi
avec un armée nationale éthiopienne à
l'armée nationale et aux peines à peu
près cent trente cinq mille hommes si
l'on peut dire
mais là dedans vous en avez 21% des
tigres est une soupe habite qui ne sont
pas appelés à combattre puisqu'on les a
mis de côté si l'on peut dire
donc vous voyez il ya énormément de
troupes qui sont montés dans le nord et
pour occuper les villes et les garder il
va falloir beaucoup plus de troupes que
cela alors en face se trouve des forces
de milices et forces de spécial si on
peut dire la police digue réel qui a
priori n'ont pas combattu donc en l'état
actuel d'activité sont peu dire donc
faut compter à peu près cent mille
hommes répartis peut surtout directoire
tigréens qui vont faire des actes de
résistance un peu comme ils l'ont fait à
l'époque 2010 tous entre 1974 991 tombe
17 ans de lutte pour mettre à bas si
l'on peut dire le dictateur qui était
mengestu donc c'est gérer leurs parents
ont eu l'habitude de ce combat au risque
d'avoir beaucoup de résistance quand
même au sein même des régions et alicia
y en aura pas d'affrontement frontale je
pense qu'il n'a pas beaucoup ce qu'elle
ait cédé les opposants tigréens si l'on
peut dire entre bien compris que face à
une armée rodez ils ont été remis
quelques difficultés à gagner donc le
rapport de force n'est pas si
défavorables plus cela en revanche au
risque d'avoir un conflit qui s'enlise
dans le temps est plutôt des actions de
guérilla de la part du tplf face à une
armée comme vous le voyez dans vos
images 2d en images avec des chars de
combat de l'artillerie mais pour tirer
ce n'est pas grand chose mais c'est un
risque de régionalisation du conflit et
et quel est le rôle que peut jouer la
communauté internationale alors
affaire rio négation de confiture dit
non parce que c'est un problème
souverain d'après la garenne et
personnels dans le ruisseau de l'afrique
ne bougera tout dans des campings c'est
un problème de souveraineté pour lui et
même l'amérique deux médiateurs envoyés
par les africaines a fait chou blanc si
l'on peut dire mais on savait puisque le
principe de l'union africaine c'est la
non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures d'un état à partir du moment
où vous n'avez pas une action de crimes
contre l'humanité de génocide et ça n'a
jamais été prouvée pour l'instant si en
plus vous n'avez pas d'image il n'est
rien il est la communauté tant elle est
notamment lié au fait qu'elle
n'interviendra jamais et l'ignorent ce
week end a déjà fait un précédent là
dessus c'est sur le burundi en 2015 2016
on n'était pas intervenus alors que
s'étaient sentis très dégradé au niveau
au niveau criville crimes contre
l'humanité crimes de guerre si l'on peut
dire donc le la meilleure ce week-end ne
bougera pas pas de régionalisation et la
communauté internationale commence un
petit peu âgées la bouger on a vu il ya
deux jours le sommeil pompéo dire il
faut garantir le respect des droits
humains des tigres et un de tous les
groupes ethniques donc ça commence à
venir si les états unis commencent à
semer un petit peu dans la danse si on
peut dire ça pourrait être important et
c'est peut-être pour ça que les couloirs
humanitaires ont commencé à être ouvert
devrait s'ouvrir
merci beaucoup à vous patrick ferrasse
pour cette année mais je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'association
stratégie africaine spécialiste de la
corne de l'afrique